upgrades to improve
clinician override rates rose's current
research focuses on the improvement of
contraceptive care
with the use of a patient-centered
sexual health
decision aid so with that rose i will
turn it over to you
thank you very much so let me
share my screen here
[Music]
okay
so thank you everyone for coming to
today um it's entitled shaping healthy
sex choices the development and
evaluation
of an interactive reproductive health to
patient decision aid
so just in the past couple of months we
have seen a transformation in the
landscape of women's health
two supreme court rulings one on
abortion services louisiana
and another on coverage of
contraceptives by the aca have changed
the way people have access to health
care
and all of these rulings have an impact
understanding and access to such
this is currently the cultivation of
this understanding
has been misinformed or not informed at
all within the past 30 years so we want
to know what led us to the point we are
at today
and so this timeline will highlight some
important moments within the evolution
of sexual health education in america
and i'll touch on a few of these points
in time so in 1892
the national education association
passes a resolution that calls for
morals education in schools
this becomes the start of sexual
education practice within the united
states
in 1918 we see huge spikes in st
syphilis in gonorrhea which causes
congress to commission
sexual education for soldiers via the
chamberlain khan act
this effort was the american hygiene
association who showed soldiers what
stds look like on the cell and human
level
other teaching methods like movies
provided another way for soldiers to
comprehend how their sexual behaviors
could cause them to catch stis
in the 1920s soldiers sexual education
soon inspired the movement of the
curriculum into schools
they started with films like the gift of
life which warned about
the vices of sexuality during this time
teachers like lucy s curtis encouraged
other teachers to teach these topics
with different materials like poetry or
english literature
and then in the 30s through the 50s here
we saw a boom in sexual education
where the office of education starts to
publish materials for teaching sexual
health topics
in the next two decades college campuses
also introduce these same materials
and in the 60s and 70s we then arrive at
the resistance to the boom and here we
see
sexual education become politicized
where religious conservatives are using
their power to enact protests across the
country
in the 1980s the aids epidemic hits and
by the mid-1990s every state has passed
mandates for education at the same time
conservatives were mobilizing to rebrand
sexual education to abstinence education
and specifically in 1996 this rebrand
was pushed into law with the welfare
reform act so
this law allowed for monies to be given
only to abstinence education programs
in the 2000 several reports like the
waxman report
determined that abstinence education was
ineffective and in some cases dishonest
and this left many students with no
instruction about most components of
sexual health
so where we are today is that we're left
with various types of sexual health
education that are not enforced
so again current policies for sexual
health education
are rooted in extensive history of
sexual health that is dated back to 1892
and some of these outdated policies
still control sexual education today
they've now created generations of
people with wildly inaccurate
information about things like healthy
relationships
non-heterosexual relationships pregnancy
sti and hiv risk the anatomy of the
female male bodies and
other topics so more specifically
abstinence-based programs are proven to
have adverse effects on young people's
sexual health
and their behaviors yet there's still
the program of choice for almost 80
percent of states that's about every
four in five states abstinence-based
sexual programs significantly impact
things like accurate and complete
information about sexual reproductive
health
decision-making about sex and
relationships and even the health needs
of racial minorities and lgbtq plus
youth
so to combat the issue of things like
absence-based education there were
several states who started to change
their education policies to
to include something called
comprehensive sexual education
and as early as 2002 defined it as the
addition to
abstinence education while also teaching
other aspects of sexual health like
contraception and disease prevention
methods
this definition has now involved to the
calc 2018 definition where we
now use the term comprehensive programs
and that's defined as medically accurate
information
on a variety of topics approach
sexuality from a positive perspective
and aiming at enhancing teens
abilities values and skills to
internalize and implement healthy
behavior
so surprisingly enough oregon started
this movement in 2009
when they set standards for
comprehensive sexual education in
schools
and this education included content on
things like consent
sexuality and identity healthy
relationships
and in 2016 these vendors were pushed
forward to start as early as
kindergarten
up to today the lack of sexual health
education has left many young people
with
little to no accurate information about
sexual health
so this can be seen as a potential
source of misinformation but
many others exist and are encountered
frequently
so the two other sources we'll talk
about today are social networks and the
internet
so when we talk about social networks i
define it as individuals chosen as
trusted sources
for the acquisition and verification of
information
research has shown that people are most
likely to rely on and trust information
given to them by family and friends
so when taking closer look at the
sentiments around that information it's
most
negative so as an example my mom told me
not to get pregnant
my mom told me not to get somebody else
pregnant
um a popular source of sexual health
information for young people
is the internet due to its accessibility
and types of internet resources do
include things like sexual health
websites and social networking sites
like facebook and instagram
yet many of these sources may be
interesting
so the most prevalent kind of internet
information young people refer to
is pornography which gives
unprofessional expectations about sexual
relationships
research does show that most young
people find internet information to be
accessible
yet unreliable
so we have seen that all of these
sources of misinformation can result in
negative effects on a person's sexual
health
and sexual behaviors so we want to know
is there another source of information
that people trust to provide medically
accurate information
and counsel patients through treatment
options and so the answer may lie within
our health care providers particularly
those who provide family planning
services
so now we ask are there any existing
tools or methods
used for sexual health teaching within
the clinic that we can leverage
so clinicians are seen as an important
resource for young people when accessing
sexual and reproductive health services
and currently there are no set
strategies for delivering sexual health
education in clinic
just ones that focus on overall sexual
health so things like sti prevention
we only see the delivery of sexual
education when it relates to a clinical
problem
or when patients feel comfortable enough
to ask about it
but patients do expect providers to
initiate these conversations about
sexual health
and they want to have conversations that
are non-judgmental so they see
the clinic as a safe space
over the years there have been many
tools that have been used to convey
sexual health messaging to patients
things like pamphlets websites text
messages
and each of these approaches have
shortfalls when it comes to their
efficiency in delivering information so
for example pamphlets and websites
need consistent updating and have it for
anyone
text-based services require access to a
phone and are limited with the amount of
information that you can deliver at once
so patient provider conversations seem
to be the best
option for them seeking sexual health
information from health care providers
but we have to know that these
conversations are best when patients are
prepared and comfortable having these
conversations
so today we want to look at
contraceptive counseling
as the current avenue for sexual health
education within the clinic
so contradictive counseling is composed
of the following four things
the first is to obtain a clinical and
social history
so here we're asking questions about a
person's sexual frequency
if they're in a monogamous relationship
if they've ever been on birth control
then we want to know about providing
education about conscious
options so here we can present some or
all options that can be prescribed to
the patient
note that some patients may already have
a method or two that they would want to
try
but here we're just giving
recommendations based on their clinical
and social histories that they
gave to us previously the third thing we
want to do is form a plan
for contraceptive usage so once the
patient has picked the contraceptive how
do we ensure that they
will use it on a consistent and
efficient basis
and the fourth thing is to obtain
assurance of correct usage so here we
verify
that the patient's understanding of the
method how it works and when to take it
is correct
and this process is typically completed
at the initial visit and
at any concurrent visits that involve
the removal change or addition of a
contraceptive method
so contraceptive counseling can be seen
as a form of shared decision making
where patients and clinicians have to
work together to find the best fit
treatment for the patient
and every time a patient sees a
contraceptive or seeks a contraceptive
the patient and provider have to sort
through many fda approved methods
to see which one
uh-oh
that's not good
okay that's weird you guys can still see
my screen i hope
we can still see the screen with
contraceptive counseling on it
great thanks it was giving me some
warning about how i'm only a participant
so it seems strange but
i'll continue so um so
there's many of these fda methods that
and we want to see which one is best fit
so many variables have to be considered
including a patient's current
medications sexual behaviors likeliness
for adherence and most importantly the
decision has to be
made by the patient so how does a
patient with little to no accurate
sexual
knowledge sort through these options
so once so this counseling technique has
been researched heavily and shows
positive outcomes for things like
increased contraceptive use
improvement in the increased use of
effective contraceptives or things known
as larks so these are long-acting
reversible contraceptives so things like
the iud
or the implant which lasts for many
years
and increased knowledge about
contraceptives
but the effects of these methods don't
focus heavily on sexual health education
so many clinicians try to touch on the
subject when it's relevant
but time is a huge barrier to providing
proper sexual health education
and one study actually emphasized in the
conclusion that general efforts to
improve
integration of contraceptive counseling
into primary care services in addition
to electronic reminders
and efficient delivery of contraceptive
information are needed
so clearly there's a need to make this
process more efficient
so our informatics question is what
informatics tools
can we leverage to make this experience
easier for patients and clinicians
so again the current issue we have with
the concept of counseling is it's
non-modification for
levels of sexual health knowledge
current contraceptive decision aids and
education materials
focus solely on positive options and
adherence without assessing or
addressing patients current sexual
health behaviors and risks
so one way that we can fix these issues
is by providing
accessible literate health information
this can be done with the use of patient
decision aids and shared decision making
principles
so what are patient decision aids well
they're evidence-based tools that help
patients become more informed
form realistic expectations and choose
among multiple
medically relevant options decision aids
have
many positive outcomes including
reducing anxiety
improving treatment satisfaction and
increasing the perception
of making an informed choice so research
already supports the feasibility of
patient decision tools for contraceptive
discussions
but a majority of these systems exist
within a specific health system
but two are currently available to the
public one is called my birth control
which was created by ucsf
and another is called what is the right
birth control for me which was created
by planned parenthood
so this is the my birth control uh tool
which was developed by ucsf and it was
used it was made to promote a shared
decision-making approach to counseling
that is rooted in women's preferences
the tool intends to mimic the
contraceptive counseling process
so the decision aid educates users about
different aspects
of making a conscious decision as we see
on the right
and through a series of education
modules and questions like we see on the
left
users are required to rank priorities to
find best fitting birth control options
the initial pilot test of the decision
aid wanted to know whether patients
accepted the tool and a majority of
study participants about 96 percent
found the tool to be acceptable
planned parenthood hosts their own
contraceptive decision aid in the form
of a quiz
and the quiz is similar to the ucsf tool
where it takes the user through a series
of questions about the patient's values
the aid also asks questions about the
patient's personal social network's
views on using the contraceptive so if i
were exploring hormonal iud would your
partner feel okay with
you using it would your family be okay
with using it how about your friends
and it also covers some socio-economic
factors that impact contraceptive choice
like access to health insurance
and so these examples showcase some of
the positives in forming decision needs
around contraceptive care
clarifying values and educating users
about conservative choices
showcases what patients can expect for
talking to a clinician
but there are issues with some of these
decision needs and how they were built
so for the ucsf decision aid there's an
assumed foundation of knowledge
patients have to have about their
anatomy and assumes only women will use
the tool
uh this excludes those who may not have
enough knowledge to sort through the
options or those who identify as female
so they may not feel comfortable using a
tool like this
in the planned parenthood decision aid
it does it's very long
it's about 20 to 30 minutes to take it
and this could be due to the redundancy
of questions
um and it's rarely used within planned
parenthood so within the columbia
willamette area
of the people that i asked about the
decision aid a majority didn't know
about it
and of the ones that did they didn't use
it because of
the previous reasons
so the question that we have now is how
do we fill the gaps of the previously
made contraceptive tools
while still trying to deliver a quality
decision aid
and so we answer this by using a new
framework
to develop a reproductive health patient
decision aid that addresses sexual
health behaviors risks and contraceptive
options
so we will do this by exploring some
aims here so the first aim is a
literature review of current
contraceptive decision aid effectiveness
so what are the key content
and design features needed to address
patient and clinician needs
the second is the development phase so
here we're developing and refining a
prototype
so here we ask what is the optimal
information
decision support and design features
that patients and clinicians find
meaningful
and the last name is the pilot and
evaluation phase of the prototype so is
the decision aid acceptable to patients
and clinicians
and does it improve patient knowledge
and we'll get back to that in a second
completion of these steps creates a
user-centered patient decision aid
so we want to talk about about the scope
of the decision aid a little bit more
give you an idea of the its intended use
so the intended audience would be
biological females who are seeking a
contraceptive
the focus is to give reproductive health
education which is relevant to making a
contraceptive choice
and the intended decision making
activity is contraceptive choice
similar to the ones that we saw
previously
the testing cohort inclusion criteria
are those who are 18 to 24 years old so
that's how we define young people in
this study
and they have to have experienced at
least one contraceptive counseling visit
we also would like to include clinicians
who have experience conducting
counseling and can prescribe
contraception
so we are excluding patients who are
pregnant and we are doing this because
we want to make sure that all options
are available to patients and we're also
excluding those who are biological males
so ideally when making a decision name
you want to have it written in plain
language and consist of the following
components
education values clarification and some
sort of coaching or tailored feedback at
the end
and in this decision aid we hope to do
the same educate users about
reproductive health topics related to
choosing a contraceptive
we want to make sure we're clarifying
values attitudes and beliefs about
contraceptives so this can
fit into the misconceptions piece a
little bit
coach users on contraceptive choice and
prepare users to talk to clinicians
about contraceptives
so in front of you you'll see the ottawa
decision support framework which
represents the core concepts of decision
making
i've adapted this framework to fit
decision making with contraceptives
so the framework provides a three-step
approach an assessment of patient and
provider needs
under decisional needs the creation of
decision support right here and the
evaluation of decision making processes
and outcomes which is decision quality
in this study we will use the decision
aid acceptability
and patient knowledge to evaluate the
feasibility of the decision aid
so acceptability measures how well a
patient comprehends pieces of the
decision made and its overall ability to
help with decision making
and knowledge measures the patient's
knowledge of all facets of a clinical
problem
so within our first aim we've already
set the scope right for our study which
was described in previous slides
so the study will start at steering our
stakeholders 1 here and the systematic
review
and here we're forming a stakeholder
panel and we end with the
final storyboards here that will build
the first prototype
so again in aim one we want to identify
the appropriate clinical evidence
decision support activities and decision
aid format
in design to address patients and
clinicians decision support needs
through literature review and the
stakeholder panel
so this again involves a literature
review of current contraceptive decision
needs and requires the construction of a
stakeholder panel which consists of
patients and clinicians
so the first outcome we have here is a
wireframe of the decision make so this
is simply
just again some storyboards we just have
visuals of what we'd like the decision
aid to look like it's not interactive
here
and our secondary outcome would be a
ranking of design features by importance
and effectiveness
and so we talked about this literature
review in the first aim a little bit
which
is to find effective design features for
our decision name
and to complete this objective we will
conduct some sort of systematic
review of current literature on mobile
or web-based contraceptive decision aids
and this will fall under a current
systematic review which is ohsu led
which is already reviewing contraceptive
care and it's led by dr heidi nelson
so here we're pulling papers from this
current systematic review to use for
this aim
in the second aim we're beginning with
an initial prototype here
that will be reviewed by the stakeholder
panel we then move into the beta testing
phase
and end with a user-approved prototype
that's ready for clinical evaluation
so again aim2 is simply to develop and
refine a prototype
here we want to require beta testing to
gauge the aids feasibility so we want to
use a maximum
of 16 participants so this is four
rounds of testing
with four participants per round so the
testing will either stop at the four
rounds or once we reach a point of
feedback saturation which simply means
that if i'm getting the same information
before i hit
the 16 participants then i'll stop at
that number
before 16. so we are collecting several
types of data here
qualitative data we're collecting is our
beta tester semi-structure interview so
we want to know what are the design
features you like the best
why did you like them what would it help
you with in your contraceptive choice
and some other data is just simply in
application comments so
what specifically works or does not work
for you in these
virtual prototypes our qualitative
analysis will be a content analysis we
want to know about things like design
things like content and again the
stakeholder panel will review the first
prototype so that's before beta testing
and the final user-approved prototype
that which is after beta testing
and our outcome is a user-tested
prototype that's ready for the pilot
test
so in our last aim which is our pilot
testing and evaluation phase we want to
begin with the clinical pre-test to
smooth out any issues with the clinical
process
and we end with the evaluation data from
our patient reported outcome measures
which are given before
and or after the decision is
administered
so here we're piloting the prototype to
assess its acceptability and its effect
on knowledge
here we want to recruit at least 31
eligible people
within a local family planning clinic
and we want to observe at least 80
acceptability and a 10 increase in
knowledge and so these evaluation
metrics and sample size calculations
perform by previous studies and a simple
power analysis
so again we intend to recruit at least
31 participants
here we're collecting some quantitative
data on our patient
patient reporter outcome data from the
questions questionnaires and the
analysis is just simple statistics
and the qualitative data is
semi-structured interviews that'll occur
with clinicians about the decision aid
what helped you within the counseling
process with the decision aid and how
would you improve on it
and again this is a content analysis so
here we have the outcome of a patient
centered uh decision aid prototype
so we do have some limitations with this
study one is
uh oregon's racial homogeneity as we all
know oregon is not the most diverse
state
so to mitigate this fact we want to test
within a local family planning clinic
because this does bring a lot of social
economic diversity within our data set
and we do have a small sample size which
is typical of qualitative or mixed
method studies but to mitigate this fact
we will use
the tool and review it and revise it
multiple times
excuse me so this proposal was submitted
to the health assessment labs doctors
association award
and the award does provide 25 000 in
doctoral dissertation research
so if the award is one we can then
proceed with building a mobile
application to test within the clinic
so the completion of the research will
produce a patient-centered decision aid
that addresses knowledge gaps is
acceptable to young people
and improves contraceptive knowledge
improved decision making provides the
space for improved awareness
improved reproductive health knowledge
and correct use of contraceptives
well that sounded weird and the correct
use of contraceptives there we go
this can decrease the risk of unintended
pregnancies and stds and also increase
scd testing and consistent contraceptive
use
and this current work will inform future
effectiveness and efficacy studies with
efficacy
being the confidence in contraceptive
and decision making ability
and of course i have to say thank you to
many people
karen eden my advisor and all the other
dmi's faculty
allison edelman in the ob gyn department
dr hoffman at md anderson cancer center
planned parenthood and dr bernadette at
planned parenthood and to
all the dms fellows andrea lynn and
diane for helping me out
anybody else who helped me along the way
and of course my funding at the nlm
and to the funding for the contraceptive
care systematic review resources legacy
fund
thank you very much
okay thank you rose for
an outstanding presentation at this
point now we'll open it up for questions
so you can if you if you have a question
you can
unmute yourself if we get several
questions at once i'll ask you to use
the chat feature
to so that we don't have people talking
over each other
i'll go ahead and open it up for
questions
rose this is chris alfie um very great
talk and
you may have already kind of addressed
this a little
but um in terms of the recruitment
and trying to kind of get at the
issues of diversity you mentioned you
know in oregon and the recruitment
um do you have any thoughts on kind of
if things don't go quite as you hope
what kind of backup plans might be
needed or do you feel pretty confident
that
it's going to go as you're expecting
because you've already kind of done a
lot of preliminary work on that
yeah so in terms of recruiting i mean it
really depends on
the area where you are you know there
are some more
um at least racial racially diverse
areas of oregon than
others um at the
i picked local family planning clinics
because they tend to be more
diverse not only racially but
socioeconomically
um if we see a trend where we're not
getting the diversity that we
want we can always you know stop at some
point and try to get
another source of
people there's also the debate of
whether you can use
do they have to be in the clinic
necessarily could you use some people
on the internet um but that also doesn't
give you a realistic
idea of how it will be used in the
clinic um
you could also use it at a place like
ohsu but again that
kind of doesn't it doesn't help with the
racial
diversity right because now we're
hopping from a local family planning
clinic to
a tertiary academic health medical
center
so it's it's hard to navigate and
so we kind of have to pick and choose
what we want to do but i
at that at this point i can't predict i
can only kind of just say
we have to see which way it goes if that
makes sense
great thank you
so again i just want to open it up if
anybody has a question
um feel free to
take your mute off and close your
question
hi rose this is allison edelman thanks
so much for such a great presentation
um as a clinician who does this work
and you mentioned this several times one
of the difficulties is always
time and then also for populations that
i mean
almost all populations don't have great
literacy
but the populations that we're seeing
that
need exposure um also may not have
the general education or ability to
interface
with electronic or virtual
means and so how are you thinking that
that might help those populations
so just to reiterate your question
you're saying how do we address
those who may not be electronically
literate with
something like a patient decision aid
correct
okay um that's a good point
uh i think that there are ways to solve
that issue i mean anything
that we have in decision aid form can
can be made into a paper-based
um decision aid it's it's not the
easiest thing to do but it's possible
i think like i was saying before with
things like pamphlets there is a pro
which is that you know anyone can go in
and read it um
so you do make a good point that you
know using something electronic can be
difficult for people who are not able to
use it but
i think that's something that we'll have
to figure out in testing is for
and potentially even find those types of
people
within our beta testing um who are low
literate
in using electronics and that will help
us with
developing this decision aid you know
how do we make sure that
people are able to use this with ease
and it doesn't take that much work
um so that is a good point that you
bring up
and then i think the other one is just
time like how long
how long something might work well for
somebody to get the information we saw
the most time
yeah so the planned parenthood one i
think
the big issue with that one was that it
took you maybe i've gone through it
multiple times it takes me anywhere from
20 to 30 minutes to use it
i think a reasonable amount of time is
about 10 to 15 minutes
um and again it's really the you re
you weigh the content you want to
deliver versus the time
and we have to balance that so that's
something again that we have to talk
about with their stakeholder panel you
know if we have a set time
then we have to prioritize what we want
to say or what information we want to
deliver
if the priority is more of the content
and we can
flex a little bit on the time then we
can prioritize you know the content a
little bit more
um but there there are ways of you know
flexing both and so i think that
in in a perfect world if you have you
know 30 minutes
with them in the room and you
potentially tell them to come
10 to 15 minutes before if we could
spare 10 minutes for them to sit down
with this decision aid and look at it
i think you know your time as a
clinician will be much more efficient
with them
in the 30 minutes that you're talking to
them
yeah i think allison i can also speak a
little bit too with a breast cancer
tool um the actual wrist screen feet
portion of it
takes most people about three minutes
and the decision aid portion took about
three to four minutes
for a total experience around seven
minutes
um the idea is not necessarily that your
conversation may be shorter but more
focused on the topics that they're most
interested in
they're the most important concerns and
questions that they have
so you know that's i i hear what you're
saying about the concern about a
technology
and be the time of use of the technology
the other thing i don't have the latest
statistics in front of me
but i getting the sense that most people
have
many uh have smartphones surprisingly
you probably know much more
practice in terms of what you see people
walking in with
but um the mobile
version of of decision has really taken
off
yeah i think one of the difficulties
about decision aids and family planning
clinics and
low resource settings is just the
connectivity um
and we even find this just going to the
planned parenthood in the city
and that the internet is not great and
it's hard to download things
and so many clicks are like that and so
if you have something that takes a lot
of bandwidth
it can be quite difficult and timely too
yeah that's a good point and
i think um just in working on the
other decision you with karen recently
um there are decision dates that you can
host that don't require internet so
they're just simply hosted on an ipad
or on the phone it's a app that lives on
the ipad so it wouldn't use any internet
so that is something that
is possible to do and that does save a
lot of resources and time for people
but it does get more difficult with when
you're venturing into you know putting
it on everybody's phone
that's when you do have to you run into
the connectivity issues
you're on mute italia
oh they still can't hear you i'll tell
you we
yeah okay now yeah i can hear headphones
um yes my question was about the 25 000
um like scholarship or
thing that you applied for um
uh do you when do you know the decision
on that and
uh what's your alternative plan if it
doesn't
if you don't get that one yeah so
currently what i presented to you is the
alternative plan
so if we're able to get the 25 000 it
will be used for development costs
mostly and also for
user testing resources uh that's what
the money will go to
um and we i hopefully will know by
november december
um but this is the
the plan right now is to create
something on my own that's easy to
manage so
wireframes and prototypes can be done
with adobe software
it's accessible to anybody but if we
want a real live mobile application that
people can use um and that can be used
moving forward then we would have to put
some money up for development costs so
that's what
mostly we would go to
i see so you're saying the web or the
apps
um your is your alternate plan
if you get that yes so if everything
if if the grant comes through then we
could create actually create a mobile
app that people could download
but currently we're saying that we're
not going to get the grant
so we'll just stay at prototype so you
know it's interactive you can click on
things
but it won't work like an app if that
makes sense
okay yeah i think too
um this also provides an opportunity for
rose to provide
and to apply for future funding to um
actually create that at that mobile app
and also test it much more broadly
than is what is currently planned i
think it's also where you would address
some of the diversity
uh concerns that i heard uh mentioned
earlier by
um so um so it gives opportunity for
future work
yes yeah for sure good luck on that
thank you
again i'll just make a call for any
additional questions
from our audience
oh i did actually have another um
another question
i just remembered towards the beginning
you were talking about you know
his difficulty with communicating with
patients
um in this sort of thing and i was kind
of wondering
how does it work with minors um
who are perhaps at risk of you know not
knowing what's going on
um but like their parents permission to
get sexual education for a um provider
and does the providers
tell the parents what occurs what we've
said during the session like
that does that how does that work
yeah so to my understanding minors
can go to say a family planning clinic
or to a planned parenthood
with the and they don't need their
parents consent to go
so anything that's said within you know
the the visit
is kept you know private they don't have
to tell the parents anything you can go
there and
get your pills things like that and
actually in oregon
you can actually go to the pharmacy and
get pills so you don't even need to go
to um a family planning clinic to get
some forms of contraception
so there there is a a modicum of there
there are
ways to get it without your parents
knowing um
but i think the difficulties that people
don't know
um and where are they going to look for
that information
if they're not getting the information
in school and if they're looking for it
on the internet
they don't they clearly don't think that
it's true
and when they're asking their family and
friends they're getting multiple
stories about what worked for them what
didn't work for them it's confusing
so we want to make sure that we're
disseminating information that's correct
and that can help if that makes sense
i think too you should emphasize that in
this particular study we have to find
the age group as 18 to 24
for your pilot work we actually aren't
including
um miners at this stage of the research
and also uh dr edmund also noted that
miners in oregon can receive
contraceptive care without consent of
parents
yeah i suppose that would be potential
challenge like different
different um rules in different areas
if uh go beyond you know
yeah you have to have um you can just
have a mobile app for every state and
have to have special
i don't know built in just to handle
different laws and stuff
exactly
uh
is there someone who would like to ask a
question heard of mike under
okay so at this point um unless there's
another question coming forward
i'd like to release the audience except
for
the committee so and if you can stay
on just for a few more minutes we'll
just kind of talk about
process i want to personally say
outstanding
presentation rose there's lots of
fabulous comments in the chat that
you know that you hopefully you can take
a look at
so thank you very much for presenting
today